well we're gonna have some pretty calm
weather here over the next several days
if you still have lights to get up and
out there in fact we'll have some good
Sunshine through the afternoon if you
want to take your Wednesday and do that
we've had some clouds overnight they're
starting to clear it is a beautiful sky
this morning but it is chilly out there
we even got some neighborhoods who found
some 30s 37 at Nellis 39 Mountains Edge
and Seven Hills 39 Sunrise Mountain and
a lot of neighborhoods that are close 34
out at Red Rock 20's up there at Kyle
Canyon in teens at Lee Canyon this
morning 30 up there in Caliente single
digits for Ely this morning with 20s in
Tonopah and Reno 36 in prompt 33 for
Indian Springs 40 in Boulder City and 48
in Laughlin Cedar City at 27 we've had
some rain and snow moving through
Northwest Arizona up into Utah and a
slight chance of maybe a snow shower
left up in our local mountains but it's
not looking too good 38 for Kyle Canyon
only 30 for Lee Canyon today and they
are officially opening for the the ski
and snowboard season today up there so
dress warm we'll have some occasional
clouds off and on cool afternoons in the
50s but really pretty close to normal
for the rest of the week now Sunday
we've got a storm coming in for the
weekend and as soon as Saturday night
but mostly Sunday a chance of Valley
rain and Mountain snow and it looks like
this one could be a pretty good
Rainmaker and snow maker for the
mountains so fingers crossed we sure
need it but that's what I mean the
timing may not be the best I know Sunday
you got to get stuff done and maybe
you'll be out and about but just plan on
it Breezy to Gusty winds too also for
Sunday into Monday so yesterday's system
has now already moved over to the east
of us but it's the residual moisture on
the back side of it we're seeing some
isolated snow showers up in Lincoln
County and we will be looking for maybe
just a light snow shower up in the local
mountains this morning 58 for the high
for the valley today 50's through the
rest of the week and then clouds move in
that late chance of showers Saturday
night but really Main mainly through the
day on Sunday even into early Monday and
we could see a quarter of an inch of
rain around some Lower Valley locations
on Sunday Gusty winds and snow and the
upper reaches of the spring mountains so
fingers crossed we need the rain and
snow
[Music]